feminism says they're for equality but  if they were they would talk about men's  issues too yeah people talk about men's  issues all the time okay I have kids  with men okay and the men don't pay for  anything and they've not been arrested  I'm saying but they legally can't I  don't I don't know who you who you know  but I'm saying legally they can go to  court if they wanted to yeah they can go  to court but it doesn't mean anything  but I'm asking how is that fair but what  about if the girl loses if the girl  loses they don't they do no they don't  that's statistically speaking women  women pay child women pay child support  like 15 of the time it's a very small  percentage it's not a very small  percentage I know a lot of boys that  have babies and don't pay anything they  don't pay anything okay I don't know who  you know but I'm going off of stats I'm  good enough stats as well